foreign
in your view when heated debate does
become tribal does become divisive does
become dangerous well you know if you
take so the example of America there's
obviously something deep really deeply
wrong happening in America and you know
both sides of the political divide
Democrats and Republicans are to some
extent
um to blame for that you know I
mentioned the deplorables thing because
throughout the Trump election rather
than there just being a criticism of
Trump's politics which you know very
easy to criticize and very easy to take
apart there was this suggestion that
everybody who would support it was a
supporter of trump was this kind of
white trash deplorable this person who
was not even worth uh politically
engaging with and of course on the flip
side you know every single critic of
trump from the mildest to the most
extreme he just labeled as a merchant of
fake news you know it was just don't
engage at all that you know it's a kind
of anyone who thinks I'm nothing but a
goddess uh making it up and so you've
had this real entrenching of
um rather than just sort of political
divides on you know important issues
like the economy or Healthcare or
whatever you've got this kind of
schoolyards school playground attitude
of just hurling you know on the one
level hurling insults at each other but
also this kind of ingrained view that we
are inherently different that one side
is evil and one side is good and you
know it only takes an issue like
abortion for example to for everybody to
suddenly realize that actually there's a
huge amount of crossover and both you
know the idea that the Democrats and the
Republicans have vast disagreements on
that is a nonsense
um so I think you know when can it
become dangerous I mean the way in which
speech becomes dangerous it was when it
crosses over into action so you know
when it becomes incitement to violence
then that's a thing when you have to um
say that there's a there's a problem but
I don't think that and also you know
what does speech being dangerous mean I
mean great speeches is having vote
revolutions throughout history which I'm
sure were dangerous for some but
liberatory for others
um you know were the reason why I'm a
journalist is because you hope that your
words aren't just going to Fritter away
and become tomorrow's chip paper but it
might stir someone to think differently
so words are powerful but I think the
idea that words and speech can become
dangerous has been too often used as a
means to have a kind of precautionary
attitude to things to censor things to
say you better not say that or what if
you know and I think that kind of
sensorious attitude is the greater evil
man
um why I'm not really sure that uh so a
lot of the mediums that we use for
so-called debates are actually debating
platforms so if I think of
um YouTube a lot of the YouTubers make
videos that are then viewed by millions
of people or hundreds of thousands or
thousands uh depending on your
popularity levels but you're basically
just speaking at people you're not
actually really engaging with others and
Twitter is also another example of a
platform where you might think you're
having a debate when you're responding
to someone in 146 characters
um but you're really not you're just
probably making a slightly flippant
Point guilty as charged I do it as well
but I'm not going to claim that I'm
engaged in a really healthy debate
that's constructive and helping me
better understand an issue same with
Facebook and I mean Facebook is another
added layer of complication which is
that you know we were talking about the
US election
um was it a third of articles that were
considered fake news I think it was
during the last president U.S
presidential election I mean the number
of Americans who were absorbing
information that was literally factually
Incorrect and carried on platforms and
then used as part of arguments for the
justifications of you know so-called
cultural Wars I think a lot of the
problem is to do with the medium I don't
think the issue is with the debate
honestly I really think that discussion
and debate is how we come to know one
another it's how we come to understand
each other's perspective but I do think
we have to be really attentive to the
platforms on which we engage in debate
and I can give you some really solid
examples I can give you a really
concrete example like
um I really like Ella we really well at
least I I have a lot of respect for Ella
in our personal time we can sit behind
the scenes and have a coffee or I'd like
to think that we get along we disagree
politically but that doesn't mean we
can't talk or that I don't have respect
for Ella and I would never insult her if
we only ever communicated on social
media you might think that we were
engaged in wars and so it really is
about checking the platforms and what
the platform service is remember the
social media companies aren't there to
help deepen democracy am I enlightening
anyone here probably not sure but we
have to really to remember that because
I think a lot of what we think of as uh
Democratic conversations that are
supposed to be helping us progress are
happening on platforms whose primary
objective is to keep you connected and
they keep you connected how by keeping
you pumped up with anger frustration
clicking the next link and none of that
is really conducive to creating a more
cohesive Society differences are great
but danger is when we step into thinking
that the person opposite us is our enemy
rather than the person we have to work
with towards a cohesive society and we
can do it we do it all the time but
instrumentalizing that exactly that
phenomenon it's not confined to social
media you see it in politics you know
absolutely that you know you attract
attention you attract yeah all manner of
things which Advance your career by by
doing exactly that
isn't that the point where it becomes
dangerous so I completely agree and I
think that um to blame it all on social
media is is an error I think that what
we can see is social media companies
exacerbate the tensions that politicians
are feeding I've just come off covering
the French elections if any of you
follow the French elections we've
basically got as polarized of political
scene as you can possibly get
um you know we've had a runoff between
the far right and a so-called Centrist
candidate for the last two uh
presidential elections and the center
has completely collapsed and that's
because the rhetoric that has been
adopted by so-called sensorous
um characters is the same rhetoric as
that of the fringes and they've done
that because the fringes when they say
something completely insane like you
know Muslims are about to take over
France and in post Sharia law boom
becomes part of a big headline the
mainstream candidates feel the need to
respond to that and that becomes the
main Mainstay of the political debate
but when you poll people on what they
actually wanted the presidential debate
to be about they said the cost of living
living standards the environment this is
what people wanted to talk about and so
politicians are to blame but so are the
platforms that we we choose to engage
with Paul you're so chill that clearly
you don't feel that anything's becoming
dangerous but is there a point in which
you would think that that heated debate
does become divisive does deepen these
problems should I try and carry on this
to your thing yeah um I mean it's
absolutely right platforms are
significant and important and question
is does that then translate into the way
that people interact with one another in
everyday life evidence at the moment of
course we don't have very many causal
pieces of evidence that's what you want
as academics you want to establish
causal effects of these different
platforms we don't have very much
in day-to-day life where there is
evidence it suggests that we're not
actually changing so you will talk to
one another in person in pretty much the
way that you always have done of course
you don't online the question then
becomes in the longer term will they
will the way in which we speak to one
another online then manifest itself in
the way that we speak to one another
when we meet people personally and
that's an open issue but for the moment
we can be chilled out
and what we'll do do culture wars play
in this because culture wars in the
question of views and identity being
merged
um surely that is the essence of
tribalism and that's something that you
know is it has been introduced I think
into public life here as well as in the
United States and that isn't that in
itself dangerous because you can't you
can't back off an argument without
backing off your identity yeah and I
think that's that you know obviously the
idea of culture wars is you know not
anything new we've had uh you know from
religious Crusades to uh you know you
know clashes of cultures just thinking
about you know areas like the 60s or
something where you had an intensely
conservative Norm coming into conflict
with uh new um more free-spirited
culture you know there's nothing new
about the idea of clashes of cultures
but the thing about the contemporary
culture wars is as you pointed out this
sense that and this is what I was trying
to get in my introduction that because
we've had and actually the the debate
that Miriam hosted yesterday about love
and drugs I sort of talked about this as
well the idea that you know everything
to do with the way in which we interact
with the world comes from our deepest
sense of self in this there I say it's
slightly narcissistic way in in which
we're in in you know encouraged to see
the most important thing as our sense of
self and our identity whether that's you
know you know the classic thing of kind
of speaking as a woman blah blah blah
speaking as a black person blah blah
blah there is this idea that the most
important thing about you is not your
ideological Outlook or what you think
about what's just happened in
Afghanistan or you know whatever things
about the world but about your it all
comes from your identity your Center the
sense of yourself and of course then
when someone disagrees with you
um like if I have a row about feminism
with someone and that I disagree with
them it's feels to them not like we're
disagreeing about the future of I don't
know Child Care policy but I'm attacking
them as a woman I'm attacking their
identity and of course there's lots of
people who do want to attack people's
identities you know racist sexists exist
in the world
um but they're but I think more
generally we've kind of we've uh
normalized the idea that there are there
are inherent barriers between us that we
cannot overcome that's what identity
politics is really to me all about is
there's this idea that there are
impossible things between us because of
our identities we've kind of really lost
this is the most important Point we've
lost faith in the idea of a universal
politics I mean particularly for those
of us on the left there has been a total
loss of the sense of a kind of universal
left-wing output look which is but just
on the point of you know of I just want
to come back to this thing on social
media just because I I think it's a
danger when we suggest that with the
wrong tools people and I'm not really
saying that Miriam's saying this but
with the wrong tools people turn into
animals you have to remember that for
example something like Twitter even
though it's yes it has become a bit of a
suspect you know at the moment you know
the excitement for many people of being
able to tweet your MP you know having
parts of politics that were completely
in closed rooms previously but with that
go go Mass death threats and trolling
and you know all kinds of things this is
the you know it's the the price for
democracy the price for free speech is
that some people aren't going to play
the game the way you want to play it
okay but that's the price of Freedom I'd
like to give them a chance to respond
um so just on that point there's a
filmmaker who I really like with dear
Khan to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas